[موسيقى]
من المعروف ان الصيام وخصوصا لفترات
تتجاوز 16 ساعه تقريبا يؤدي الى انخفاض ما
يسمى بالكوليسترول الضار
وان هذا وانه هذا الامر ينعكس ايضا على
الحميد فيرتفع بشكل جيد وهذا ومهمه اللي
هو ازاله الكوليسترول من الجدران الشرايين
ومعروف خطر الكوليسترول
ارتفاع بتشكل ما يسمى بالعصيده الشريانيه
التي تترسب على جدران اوعيه الدمويه بماده
لحدوث الجلطات القلبيه او الدماغي طبعا
رمضان فرصه مهمه جدا لتخفيض هذا النسبه
هذا المستوى العالمي الكوليسترول
اولا يجب ان يلتزم المريض الذي يستخدم
الادويه في رمضان باستعمال هذه الادويه
واكمالها في شهر الصيام لان هذه الادويه
لا تختلط تعديل كما يحدث عند استعمال
ادويه السكر مثلا الامر الثاني يجب على
المصابين ايضا
باكثار من السوائل في رمضان لان كثره
السوائل تؤدي الى عدم تشكل او تنقص من
نسبه احتماليه حدوث خثرات واعيه او جلطات
دمويه من الامور الاخرى المهمه ايضا موضوع
المشي او الرياضه في رمضان واقلها المشي
تقريبا لمده 30 دقيقه خمس مرات من اسبوع
او ما يتعدى 150 دقيقه افضل اوقات قبل
الافطار مباشره او بعد الافطار بساعتين من
الامور الاخرى المهمه ايضا الحرص على
تناول كميات جيده من
الاطعمه من الحاويه على الكربوه يدرات غير
المشبعه او الزيوت غير
المشبعون غير مشروع لانها تساعد في خفض
نسبه الكوليسترول
كموضوع زيت الافوكادو او السمك او سمك
السلمون او زيت الزيتون او الجوز واللوز
[موسيقى]